- Free walking tours here.
Free walking tours all day.
Downtown Los Angeles.
- Best walking tour
in the city.
- Free walking tours!
- Ladies?
Three of you, two of us?
There's another lady behind you.
- You know Charles Manson
killed 19 people right up there.
Yup.
So join us.
- So we're doing a free
walking tour today,
if you're interested.
- Jamarcus... did you
play for the Cowboys?
- No.
- There's sunscreen
in that doughnut.
We're going to be
out in the sun a lot.
- Hello my name is David.
- This is my brother David.
- I'm David.
This is our free walking tour.
And it begins right here
at the central library
right here behind us.
This was built in 1926
and it's been housing
all the wackos and
kooks since that moment.
- Before we go...
- Oh!
- I would like to...
Is it okay if I say a
prayer over everyone?
- Please do.
- Okay.
- Just take his hands please.
Electricity, everybody just
take each other's hands.
- Sweet baby Jesus
please protect us
from our enemies and the
citizens of this city
that wish to do...
- Okay moving on!
(upbeat music)
(sweet music)
Okay so now we're under
the library tower.
If everybody looks
up, straight up...
And imagines
themselves on a beach
with no clothes on.
And you can wrap your
legs around this building,
you'd have the tallest
penis in the West.
- The tip of which would have
a McDonald's and a Jacuzzi.
- Just a couple of
things I want to tell you
about Joseph Scott.
he was a beloved citizen,
distinguished lawyer,
stalwart champion
of Americanism.
He practiced law in Los
Angeles from 1894 to 1958.
- Also this is the
most masturbated to
statue in the city.
- And if you look above you
you'll see more buildings.
- Well that's a PT
Cruiser right there.
Car of the future.
The Westin Bonaventure Hotel!
Hey, can anybody tell
me what it's made of?
- Metal?
- That's right.
Metal and glass.
- Glass.
- You guys...
I don't even know
why we're here.
- Alright come on.
Come on. Come on.
Come on.
Sir, you stay over there.
- This right here is named
the Dorothy Chandler Pavilion,
and is the crowning
achievement of Miss Chandler.
Her previous crowning
achievement was
she had seven orgasms
in seven minutes.
Come on, hurry!
(intense music)
Who's hungry?
Anybody hungry?
Well there's one
thing we did for you
on this free walking tour.
We provided you with one of
L.A.'s finest food trucks.
Here it is right here.
The Diablo Huevos and
bologna sandwiches.
(crowd cheers)
Who likes deviled eggs?
Come on, join us!
- Hello my friends!
It's so good to see you!
You want deviled egg
or bologna sandwich?
- Yes, bologna sandwich.
- All we have left is
open-faced. (laughs)
Oh, here we go!
No, no I do it to you.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh yes!
It's so good!
(mariachi music)
- Muscles, everybody.
Muscles.
Some interesting
information about this sign.
Now Los Angeles has
25 sister cities.
And yes, they do all get
their period at the same time.
- Interesting thing about
the Biltmore Hotel David,
is it is the most haunted
building in the world.
Maybe because it's built
on an ancient Chinese
burial ground.
- This right here is one
of the last remaining hold outs
from the Occupy Wall
Street movement.
(screaming)
As you can see, this is
titled the Broad Plaza.
It's a tribute to
women in Los Angeles.
(string music)
Okay, so this is one
of my favorite
corners in the city.
Right behind me that is
the Walt Disney Concert Hall.
Frank Gehry has
deemed the bathrooms
in that place
acoustically perfect.
- I would also like to
point out that it's built
on an ancient Disney
burial ground.
- Behind you if we
can all turn around...
There's a great sculpture
there of Daniel Day Lewis.
(upbeat music)
Right now is the
end of the tour.
- Concludes the end
of the tour, yes.
(crowd moaning)
- Part one.
We're now starting part two.
Pile on in!
- I told you
there would be a limo.
Nancy Joe!
Lady Purple!
Joey Satrioani!
- Satch!
Take her away, Rick.
- Take it away!
(upbeat music)
- Hey everybody.
We're the Walsh Brothers.
And after you've written
whatever the hell
you wanted to write
underneath the video...
Hopefully it's terrible
and negative and...
We love that shit.
Go back and watch
the video because...
- Because we've hidden
a secret button.
- He hid the button.
- Somewhere on our
favorite expression.